bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nu mais
pour ce nouveau pardon numéro de
kiosques chose que votre magazine dédié
à la culture sur 50 en ville et ses
environs
tout de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi
16 septembre pour cette émission
spéciale journées du patrimoine où nous
irons à lober excuse observatoire de
versailles saint quentin en yvelines
nous nous rendons également à l'apei de
go royal des champs qui ouvre sa
chapelle celle ci était fermé depuis 30
ans et enfin nous découvrirons la salle
du congrès du château de versailles
exceptionnellement ouvertes visiteurs le
musée lambinet à versailles inaugure une
nouvelle exposition lors de ces journées
du patrimoine
il retrace l'évolution de la figure du
héros au cours des siècles sur les
toiles de jouy renommée les ateliers de
la manufacture fondée en 1760 par
christophe philippe oberkampf
et comme chaque semaine notre rendez
vous cinéphile nous découvrirons vos
avis et les coups de coeur de guaino au
grenier à sel de trappes
nous débutons donc par un programme
spécial journées du patrimoine sur saint
quentin en yvelines journée d'autant
plus importante pour saint-quentin parce
que cette année c'est le patrimoine du
xxème siècle qui mise à l'honneur
alors pour en parler lors fall est
chargé du label ville d'art et
d'histoire au musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines
bonsoir et éric allain jules s vice
président en charge de la vie culturelle
et associative à la communauté
d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines bonsoir je
sois l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a reçu le label ville d'art et
d'histoire en 2006 c'est la première
ville nouvelle est la première ville
essentiellement construite dans la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle à recevoir
ce label créé en 1985 alors et les
câlins jeunesse
expliquez nous en quoi consistent ces
labels alors ce label est attribué donc
par les services du ministère de la
culture
il correspond
à la fois deux entités une
reconnaissance de la qualité de la
valeur d'un parti du patrimoine donc
d'une collectivité locale et en même
temps un engagement de cette
collectivité à le valoriser à le
promouvoir et à mieux le faire connaître
et à le conserver
et la thématique de l'édition 2015 qui
est le patrimoine du 21e siècle at elle
une résonance particulière pour saint
quentin en yvelines qui est une ville
nouvelle absolument puisque nous sommes
à saint quentin en yvelines
dotée d'un patrimoine qui est
essentiellement tourné sur la deuxième
moitié donc du 20e siècle et sur le 21e
siècle puis de par son histoire et donc
il y a dans saint quentin en yvelines
tout un certain nombre de de deux
patrimoines architecturaux tout à fait
remarquable et qui font de cette de
cette ville une véritable musée à ciel
ouvert le label ville d'art et
d'histoire porte une importance
particulière à la vélo à la valorisation
et à la médiation autour du patrimoine
des villes qui qui profitent de ce label
alors nous allons découvrir avec laure
valette la programmation établie autour
de ces journées du patrimoine sur
saint-quentin quelques dates peut-être
quelques dates
oui de l'euro n'a littéraire à l'arrivée
de port royal le samedi
il ya énormément de choses mais le
dimanche vous aurez le loisir de vous
promener sur le site de l'abbaye de port
royal des champs à travers une promenade
ils terre on est tout à fait dans le
thème patrimoine du xxème siècle puisque
la comédienne véronique ellena malvoisin
sur proposition de la maison de la
poésie s'est associé au musée national
de peau réelles des champs pour proposer
lectures d'auteurs du 21ème siècle qui
vous feront voyager à travers la
littérature et le site de port royal en
développant le regard des écrivains
contemporains sur ce site historique de
grande valeur donc ce sera une date sur
le site de port royal des champs je sais
également que port royal des champs a
prévu d'autres activités justement
williams elle s'est rendue à port royal
des champs ce week-end on envoie
quelques images le domaine national de
port royal des champs son abbaye fondée
au xiiie siècle ces bâtiments datant du
xvième et xviième siècle dont le
pigeonnier et le moulin et enfin son
corps de ferme abritant aujourd'hui le
musée construit entre le 17e et 19e
siècles ou pas royal n'existe que parce
qu'il y avait eu au xviie siècle cette
opposition frontale des gens de l'église
avec le pouvoir du roi et notamment avec
le pouvoir de louis xiv ce mouvement
qu'on a appelé le jansénisme qui est un
mouvement religieux qui s'oppose de
façon brutale à l'absolutisme royal
ce week end les journées du patrimoine
met trop l'accent sur la découverte du
site de l'abbaye généralement délaissé
au profit du musée un haut lieu culturel
propice à un voyage à travers les
siècles
plusieurs visites sont programmées dès
lors des visites
adapté pour les personnes malentendantes
ou malvoyantes
ce qui d'une façon différente de
découvrir le site
il ya possibilité aux sur le site de
l'abbaye de pouvoir découvrir l'oratoire
qui est rouvert exceptionnellement pour
ces journées du patrimoine après trente
ans de fermeture de la même manière sur
le site de l'abbaye il y aura un accueil
sur les jardins médicinaux et la
possibilité de pouvoir faire une
promenade autour de l'étang des
religieuses là encore ce sont des
endroits qu'on ne voit pas
habituellement qui ne sont pas ouverts
au public le musée proposera de revenir
sur une page importante de l'histoire de
france
l'affrontement entre les jansénistes et
le roi soleil qui a conduit à la
destruction de l'abbaye de port royal
alors on va l'être d'autres événements
littéraires sont ils prévus
tout à fait on change de l'ambiance et
on va sur du patrimoine contemporain
mais on reste dans ce changement de
regard avec toujours des lectures pour
découvrir un artiste qui était très
important localement qui ait fuit le
laos
l'auteur notamment des golgoths à
guyancourt et autour de ces gogos de la
médiathèque rousseau dans le quartier de
villas roi a proposé une petite
exposition d'oeuvres de dessins de
l'artiste et s'est associé à la maison
de la poésie encore une fois pour
proposer une lecture par le comédien
laurent sentent de la compagnie verts
volants pour vous faire voyager à
travers la vie et l'oeuvre de philo la
housse donc quelque chose de très
sensible de très ludique pour découvrir
cette oeuvre par elle même très
accessible et visite de la bibliothèque
universitaire est également prévu tout à
fait le samedi matin
vous pourrez découvrir ce bâtiment
emblématique de l'architecturé
contemporaine puisque c'est un bâtiment
du 21ème siècle qui puise dans la
référence architecturale du xxème siècle
à savoir le corbusier donc vous
découvrirez toutes les clés pour
comprendre l'architecturé également le
fonctionnement et les coulisses de la
bibliothèque universitaire éric alain
giniès est-ce que ça avait un coup de
coeur sur cette programmation des
journées du patrimoine c'est dit
visiblement un coup de coeur il ya des
des lieux particulièrement
intéressant notamment le 21e siècle sera
tourné sur sur le sport et je crois que
c'est une occasion de découvrir
notamment les coulisses du vélodrome
nationale qui est la plus grande piste
du monde
il y aura aussi la possibilité d'aller
sur le golf national de découvrir ces
quelques années de la riderz cup et je
crois peut-être si vous me demandez un
coup de coeur je crois que c'est
l'occasion de visiter aussi les
entrailles du théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de la scène
nationale que j'ai eu l'occasion de
visiter pour moi même et qui sont
vraiment tout à fait surprenante alors
avant de partir sur les rendez vous
sportifs que vous et vieux que vous
évoquez à l'instant on va rester avec le
monde étudiant pour se rendre à l'hôt vs
qu observatoire de versailles saint
quentin ou bien qui exceptionnellement
également ouvrira ses portes ce week end
samedi 19 septembre les journées du
patrimoine saint vital ovs qu
observatoire de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
l'occasion de découvrir un équipement
scientifique rarement ouverts au public
et de comprendre les missions de cette
composante de l'université
en plus de la formation des étudiants
l'observatoire a aussi une mission
d'observation
alors ça peut être l'observation des
planètes mais aussi l'observation de
l'atmosphère ou de l'océan dans notre
cas on a des services d'observation de
l'atmosphère et notamment des gaz à
effet de serre et puis on s'occupe aussi
des de la recherche interdisciplinaire
entre les différentes unités qui
composent l'observatoire de laboratoire
composent le vs qu un laboratoire de
planétologie pour étudier l'atmosphère
sur les plaines étaient sur terre le
latmos est un laboratoire d'étude
d'adaptation au changement climatique
avec un travail particulier sur le
groenland et la sibérie lové est-ce que
participe à de nombreuses missions
spatiales notamment filets une de leur
grande fierté
en ce moment on a aussi des instruments
sur le rover martien curiosity est là on
croit pas on prépare le prochain euro
vers donc salée rover martien c'est
quand même des expéditions on a à bord
laboratoire chimique des radars pour
sonder le sous-sol pour voir si
effectivement il y avait de l'eau il y
avait de la vie donc là aussi c'est des
expédients fabuleux mercure ça va être
la première une grosse mission autant de
mercure donc là aussi une grande
découvrir samedi pour les journées du
patrimoine
il y aura notamment une visite de la
plateforme de l'eau vs cul qui permet de
tester les instruments envoyé dans
l'espace pour analyser l'atmosphère des
planètes les instruments d'exploration
seront expliquées il y aura même
quelques pièces de collection on va
comme cet usage ouvrir les portes des
laboratoires et on va montrer un petit
peu les réalisations qui sont faites ici
alors sous deux formes soit des formes
un petit peu d'ateliers mais aussi des
formes un peu plus visite de choses où
les gens auront loisir du coup de poser
directement les questions aux chercheurs
qui seront là donc sans être
complètement préparé les gens viennent
avec leurs questions leurs
interrogations
ils vont pouvoir les avoir des réponses
j'espère qu'ils aient satisferont pour
participer aux ateliers prévus dans les
laboratoires n'oubliez pas de vous
inscrire auprès du musée de la ville
contre plus sportives sont également
prévues ce week-end je pense notamment
toutefois avec un clin d'oeil culturel
avec la restauration de la porte du
maire on a expliqué fictivement on peut
même parler plus que d'un clin d'oeil
puisque c'est un monument historique non
protégé au titre des monuments
historiques qui est la dernière porte du
grand parc de versailles qui encore
aujourd'hui visibles sur saint quentin
en yvelines qui se trouve dans le golfe
sûre magny les hameaux et qui a été
magnifiquement restaurée et inaugurée
cette année à l'occasion de l'open donc
on pourra rentrer dedans très
exceptionnellement en visitant le golfe
lors des journées du patrimoine
tout à fait laure valette eric allain
jeunesse merci vous restez en plateau
quelques dates supplémentaires à noter
dans vos agendas
samedi dimanche vous êtes attendus pour
visiter les coulisses du vélodrome et
découvrir tous les sports qui sont
pratiqués au programme cyclisme bmx
kickboxing sont bas et d'autres
activités
également ce week end
et découvrir les cultures du potager du
roi et leurs déclinaisons biologique
enfin à la base de loisirs laissez vous
tenter par un jeu de piste sur les
traces de louis xiv autour du plan d'eau
de l'île des loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines et on poursuit notre émission
spéciale journées du patrimoine en
partant au château de versailles
ce week-end la salle du congrès du
château sera exceptionnellement ouverte
regardez ce que je vous disais avec les
marches et l'écolo laquelle est prononcé
la nomination du nouveau président fait
ce week-end pour les journées du
patrimoine une ouverture exceptionnelle
celle de la celle du congrès du château
de versailles
aménagée sous la troisième république au
centre de l'ale du midi du château
cet hémicycle et le plus grand de france
1500 personnes peuvent y siéger le
congrès qui regroupe sénateurs et
députés six réunis à la demande du
président de la république
la réunion des chambres en congrès à
versailles ne se fait que pour des 30
ans des transformations de loi ou
créations de loi constitutionnelle
l'autre événement qui peut susciter le
rassemblement des chambres ici même à
versailles en congrès
c'est une demande de la part du
président public c'est une décision
récente de monsieur nicolas sarkozy que
de pouvoir avoir un lieu où ils puissent
s'exprimer devant les deux chambres
assemblée et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ça a été le cas en 2009
notamment pour les journées du
patrimoine un parcours est mis en place
à travers des pièces habituellement
fermés au public la salle dussault
utilisé pour authentifier les actes
officiels du congrès les appartements
des présidents du conseil et du sénat ou
encore l'escalier de provence sur le
qualité présenté le président du congrès
en haut de la salle marengo la visite
d'ailleurs que nous ferons
lors de ces journées européennes du
patrimoine porte autant sur l'hémicycle
que ce l'ouverture des salles et qui
servait à l'organisation des congrès
dont notamment dans l'aide du midi du
château des salles empire napoléonienne
qui évoque toute l'épopée napoléonienne
et qui vont nous permettre aussi
d'évoquer avec l'état au dessus et la
galerie des batailles toute cette
période de l'histoire de france qui est
évoquée sous la troisième république
cette visite portant donc toute une
charge d'émotion historique pour aboutir
à cet hémicycle et à sa symbolique forte
la république et la thématique retenue
cette année pour les journées du
patrimoine au château de versailles
l'occasion de traiter des questions
d'appartenance citoyenne et on reste à
versailles le musée lambinet qui a pour
habitude de démarrer sa saison lors du
week-end des journées du patrimoine
offre une exposition en l'honneur de la
disparition de christophe philippe
oberkampf fondateur de la manufacture de
jouy en josas en 1760
cette exposition retrace l'évolution de
la figure du héros au travers des
siècles sur les toiles de jouy pour en
parler nous recevons nous recevons
marion chaque 1000 est chargée des
publics et de la communication au musée
lambinet bonsoir alors mario cheikh
miley expliquez-nous ce procès des cas
importés
monsieur over kampf de grande-bretagne à
jouy en josas et qui a fait toute la
renommée de sa manufacture oui alors aux
peurs comme fonde sa manufacture donc à
jouer en josas et à ce moment là on
utilisait un système de plaques en bois
afin d'imprimer les toiles donc c'était
assez long
demander un certain nombre donc de 12
ouvriers afin de réaliser une toile
c'est conséquente et donc au beurre
comme voyage et s'agit donc de trouver
un moyen d'améliorer sa technique est en
effet il avait repéré en angleterre un
procédé utilisant des plaques de cuivre
qui sont assez importantes puisqu'elles
peuvent faire à peu près 1 mètre par un
mètre à peu près et ce sont donc des
plaques de cuivre qui sont insérés dans
une presse qui permettent des dessins
beaucoup plus fin puisque donc la
gravure est plus fine et notamment de
représenter des personnages donc ça va
être la naissance donc de toile dit à
personnage qui veut diversifier la
production a joui puisque on avait
auparavant surtout des motifs de fleurs
par exemple ou des motifs un peu plus
grossier alors pour qu'on comprenne bien
en fait là la nouveauté ont réutilisé
une plaque de cuivre tandis qu'avant il
s'agissait de plaques de bois où l'on
devait n'ont pas utilisé une presse
mécanique mais c'était un travail à la
main donc beaucoup plus long exactement
c'est pour ça qu'on peut se dessiner sur
une production beaucoup plus massive
si l'on puisse dire alors l'importance
de la toile de jute revêt une
particularité c'est qu'à l'époque on
recevait dans sa chambre qui était un
lieu social et par la parure que l'on
était dans sa chambre
c'est un moyen de communiquer sur les
valeurs desquels on se revendique eh oui
tout à fait en choisissant dans les
magasins de
jouée par exemple une toile évoquant des
héros de l'antiquité on pouvait montrer
qu'on était instruit qu'on avait lu
l'histoire antique et puis en même temps
donc on s'arroger les qualités de ce
héros par exemple l'histoire de sophonie
sme que nous voyons de là à l'écran et
évoque l'histoire d'une femme forte qui
à carthage donc pendant les guerres
puniques va décider de se donner la mort
plutôt que d'être livré aux mains des
envahisseurs des romains voilà donc
montrer l'histoire de deux sophonie sme
dans sa chambre c'était une façon de
montrer que nous avions les mêmes
valeurs
alors justement pour narrer cette
histoire c'était le même procédé utilisé
que sur les bandes dessinées plaçait
plusieurs motifs côte à côte
oui tout à fait le système delà de la
toile imprimée imposé en effet que l'on
choisisse différents moments importants
de la vie de ce personnage et donc la
toile forcément on fait un mètre de
large donc il faut choisir quelle scène
on va représenter d'abord est forcément
donc la toile va être répétitives
donc il faut faire très attention donc à
ce moment précis donc en général ce sont
des moments qui résume les hauts faits
de la vie donc de deux de ses de ces
deux personnages voilà on voit l'image
des toiles principalement rouge et
blanche il ya t'il une raison à cette
teinture
alors oui tout à fait c'est lié aux
procédés techniques puisque
la la la toile de coton et blanches et
on souhaite que la couleur soit lavables
1 qu'elle persiste au fil du temps donc
le procédé technique en fait on le
connaît on le connaissait déjà
auparavant puisque déjà deux mille ans
avant jésus-christ on a des traces de
ces procédés c'est à dire que l'on
utilise qu'on appelle des morts dans des
produits comme des sels d'aluminium par
exemple qui vont une fois appliquée sur
la toile retenir les teintures donc la
plaque en fait qu'il va être appliqué
sur la toile de coton va imprimer
d'abord les mordant et c'est une fois
les mordant appliquée que l'on trempera
la toile dans une cuve remplie de
liquide à base de garance c'était la
teinture rouge en fait et ça va agir
comme un révélateur
une foule et mordant en fait vont
attraper en quelque sorte le rouge de la
garance et faire apparaître les motifs
donc ensuite on entendait les toiles de
coton sûr on disait sur le pré afin que
le fond blanc blanchissent au soleil
donc on avait en a du coup ce contraste
de motifs rouges donc la garance en fait
peut donner des variantes donc on ça va
du roseau violer par rapport à un fond
très blanc
ses toiles de jouy nous ont permis de
constater qu'il ya une évolution de la
figure du héros au travers des siècles
notamment de 1770 à 1800 40
on part sur un héros très guerrier dans
l'antiquité à une évolution de cette
figure expliquez nous oui alors en effet
là le choix des thèmes pratiques et donc
à jouy en josas mais aussi dans toutes
les autres manufactures normande
nantaise
bordelaise par exemple reflète l'idée
que l'on se fait du héros
à ce moment là et c'est un moment
charnière puisque encore au xviie siècle
on choisit surtout des héros antiques
qui sont réputés d'abord pour leur
courage à la guerre et en même temps
évidemment d'autres vertus la maîtrise
de soi même le respect malgré tout les
honneurs à l'ennemi mais petit à petit
donc au xviiie siècle des écrivains
comme voltaire ou comme jean-françois
marmontel vont préférer des héros qui
sont plus des grands hommes et qui sont
plus par exemple des philosophes comme
rousseau qu'ils y brillent par leurs
plumes ont par leur humanité et c'est
alors en même temps au début du 19e
siècle on re découvre le moyen-age on re
découvre aussi la renaissance et on
apprécie l'anecdote est très souvent
donc cette peinture dite troubadours qui
apparaît dans les dessins que l'on
choisit dans les manufactures de toiles
imprimées et évoque donc plutôt le roi
henri iv mais au travers de ses amours
ou à la chasse ou mary stuart comme on
le voit ici l écran auprès de ses amants
alors mario jacques millet merci
beaucoup
on pourra retrouver donc cette
exposition au musée lambinet et tout de
suite nous passons à notre minute cinéma
cette année encore vous avez la parole
que pensez-vous des films à la fiche
vous avez sur les nouveautés de ce 7
septembre au nick rhodes et le diwan
film c'est un très bon film
et puis c c'est bien c'est pas un
thriller mais c'est bien ça c'était bien
les crimes a été bien écrit mais bon ce
n'est la chose positive moi je pensais
qu'il a aidé des gens qui était malade
d'un cancer
oui j'ai bien aimé c'est comme un
thriller en fait en suisse a quand même
un film à suspense
on peut mais tragique pour fisher visite
à une bande dessinée animée et
distrayante vauxhall sa revisite un peu
le mythe de napoléon solo donc c'était
assez 100 par un moment leur s est très
bien fait ça ça ressemble un peu aux
séries des années 60 70 soit sur le
napoléon solo ça nous rappelle notre
jeunesse est là s'est modernisé quoi il
ya un peu plus d'effets spéciaux c'est
les décors sont magnifiques
très sympa très sympa rétro années
soixante dix à peu près ça fait penser
en terme de deux d'image
aux mosaïques de amicalement vôtre et
puis bon trio est très sympa et les
programmateurs de salles nous donnent
leurs coups de coeur également chaque
mercredi leur reviennent sur l'événement
à ne pas rater
aujourd'hui segal pineau au grenier à
sel de trappes bienvenue au grenier à
sel cette semaine je voudrais vous
présenter nos coups de coeur c'est le
tout nouveau testament le dernier film
de jaco vandormael qui avait réalisé en
96 ça fait longtemps déjà le huitième
jour avec daniel auteuil qui rencontre
un handicapé mental qui c'est qui se
prend d'affection pour lui donc c'est le
film qui l'a le plus connu mais il avait
d'autres films depuis donc cette année
il revient avec une comédie grinçante et
corrosive dans laquelle dieu existe et
habite à bruxelles
il est incarné par benoît poelvoorde et
il est odieux ils n'arrêtent pas
d'inventer de nouvelles règles pour
embêter les gens sur terre et les sa
fille il a une fille qui s'appelle et à
décide
de se faire remarquer et envoie à toute
la population un sms indiquant la date
et l'heure de leur mort alors ça
entraîne des situations assez incroyable
des personnes qui se veut puisque je
vais pas mourir maintenant je peux me
jeter par la fenêtre de savoir s'il
s'agit d'un canular ou si cette fameuse
date de décès se confirme je peux dire
que cette fois je suis petite fille
cheveux noirs qu'allons-nous faire du
reste de notre vie est la question la
plus fréquente sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est assez incroyable c'est assez
marrant on retrouve yolande moreau
catherine deneuve benoît poelvoorde dont
françois damiens qui sont d'environ
vraiment vraiment délicieux pendant deux
semaines au cinéma le grenier à sel pour
trouver tout ça sur cinéma grenier à sel
point com et j'ai aussi quelques coups
de coeur nos prochains coups de coeur ce
sera la f1 biopic sur james dean et
helios le dernier film de paolo
sorrentino où on retrouve michael caine
et harvey keitel dans des rôles vraiment
vraiment contre à contresens et c'est un
bonheur voilà à bientôt j'espère enfin
du kiosque pour cette semaine je vous
retrouve la semaine prochaine mercredi
23 septembre aux mêmes horaires pour un
nouveau point sur l'actualité émission à
voir et à revoir sur notre site internet
très bonne soirée à tous